[Musique]
le fil d'actualités qui ne s'actualise
plus plus aucune notification facebook
whatsapp instagram le coeur des réseaux
sociaux a cessé de battre sous le regard
incrédule de leurs quelque trois
milliards et demi d'usagers s'est
répercutée alors déjà en bourse je
regardais à la clôture -4
89% la fortune de mark zuckerberg étant
aussi constitué d'actions mais bloomberg
a calculé que mécaniquement il a perdu
six milliards d'euros dans cette
histoire certains étaient prêts à
retourner sur les désuets caramail et
autres msn mais c'est surtout twitter
qui en a profité
le réseau fanfaronnait d'ailleurs en
souhaitant la bienvenue à tous les
nouveaux arrivants les problèmes sont
loin d'être terminés pour le groupe qui
est dans la tourmente puisque en même
temps il ya une lanceuse d' alerte qui
fait de graves accusations notamment sur
la nocivité d'instagram pour les
adolescentes et ce qui est super
tragique c'est que la propre recherche
de facebook deals alors que ces jeunes
femmes commencent à semer ce contenu et
elles deviennent de plus en plus déprimé
et cela les incite en kata utiliser
davantage l'application l'histoire était
pourtant belle makram akrout anciens
sans papiers tunisien devenu boulanger a
remporté cette année la meilleure
baguette de paris le réseau social est
aussi accusé d'avoir baissé la garde sur
la modération après l'élection de baden
et avant la pâque du capitole il ne
fournira finalement pas l'elysée pendant
un an comme le veut la tradition en
cause une polémique sur facebook makram
akrout est suspecté d'avoir relayé des
messages rédigés en arabe critique voire
hostiles à la france j'aime pas si je
suis droite mais jamais été de gauche
même john même jeune j'ai pas envie
d'être snob et j'ai pas envie d'être du
camp de ceux qui ont la vérité révélée
bon et je suis pas sectaire
je souscris à la nécessité de faire un
grand nettoyage c'est pas possible que
ça continue comme ça les gens vivent
dans une insécurité
il n'est pas n'est pas un horizon de
civilisation je récuse ce qui même dans
ma famille politique ont pris eric
zemmour pour cible je ne crois pas que
ça soit la bonne méthode s'il ya quelque
chose qui m'énerve aujourd'hui c'est pas
qu'on parle d'eux est mort parce que ça
c'est délitement de notre société ce
qu'on parle ce qu'on ne parle pas de ce
qui intéresse les français on s'amuse à
ces matchs de catch qu'on a tous les
jours à la télé de l'extrême gauche
contre l'extrême droite de l'extrême
droite contre l'extrême droite
l'indépendance de la france pour le
général de gaulle et pour moi gaulliste
ça passe par le rassemblement des
français et pas par des déchirures
supplémentaires le pays est déjà un
archipel de communauté peut-on vraiment
se battre pour conserver la france telle
que nous la connaissons est telle que
nous l'avons connue est tel que nos
parents nous ont transmises ou des voix
acceptons-nous qu'elle bascule dans une
civilisation qui ne sait plus qui ne
seraient plus chrétienne et
gréco-romaine voilà c'est tout c'est ça
l'enjeu le premier problèmes qui se
posent au pays c'est qu'on veut pas que
la france disparaissent on veut pas que
nos valeurs que notre mode de vie que
notre identité que notre histoire on est
sommée détester notre histoire de
déboulonner nos statuts emmanuel macron
a visité un refuge en haute saône pour
subtilement s'adresser aux amis des
animaux tout le monde est attaché à la
condition animale pour permettre de
prendre soin de ses chiens et des chats
pour la modernisation dans le secteur de
la poule pondeuse
nappe noire sur près de 34 kilomètres
carrés trois jours après qu'un oléoduc
ce soit rompue au large de la californie
près de 500 mille litres de pétrole
continuent de menacer les côtes je
m'appelle nicolas sarkozy je baisse pas
la tête pour quelque chose que j'ai
préco me je le dis sans aucune
agressivité mais je le dis
une urgence de vous adressiez à
plusieurs catégories
pas encore parlé le président de tous
les français il déguste continue jusqu'à